welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Spider-Man across the spider verse
was super dope right but I couldn't help
but notice that there were some
incredible versions of Spider-Man that
were blatantly left out of the film
that's not acceptable why would you do
that okay that film was pretty crowded
but still today we are going to name the
best versions of Spider-Man that Sony
would be silly to not include in beyond
the spider-verse even though they did
not include them in across the spider
verse I'll forgive you this time lord
Miller only this once spider people that
aren't live action Toby Andrew or Tom
because let's face it we all already
know that we are going to get our
favorite spider Trio eventually in some
type of form in this Trilogy so let's
get into this list of missing Spider-Man
together my nerd babies but first I know
it is the season for wild speculation
but I want you guys to know that I am
not a scroll okay I'm not a scroll I'm
totally not a scroll um even though
there are rumors I'm not a scroll and
you can get this shirt as well over at
nerd right at that shop to let people
know that you are not Pro and speaking
of secret Invasion secret Invasion
season is here and so be sure to tune
into new rockstars every Wednesday for
our secret Invasion breakdowns and even
more secretive race and discussion on
our newest channel the break room where
all of my friends are I miss all of them
dearly this show is filled with
conspiracies research walls and more
crazy details and we'll be breaking it
all down on new rock stars and the break
room
[Music]
all right if we're gonna make a list of
the most important spider people that
need to be included in beyond the
spider-verse I would be remiss if I
didn't start with the goat him self from
the 94 animated Spider-Man series for a
lot of kids who are developing their
imagination in the 90s this version of
Spider-Man was our first ever exposure
to the character like this was the first
animated Spider-Man that felt like a
real badass hero you know after those
60s and 80s Spider-Man spent all that
time being goofy just my luck I guess
but even though this version of
Spider-Man was never actually able to
punch any of his villains because of the
strict limitations of violence in kids
television at that day my dumbass
literally never noticed until I turn
into an adult it's because they made
Peter Parker struggles with all these
complex villains so damn interesting to
not have the Peter Parker and the Ugly
Polo and Beyond the spider verse would
be a crime Sony he is one of the biggest
reasons that Spider-Man animations are
still so big today he's the one that
made it cool he made Spider-Man cool
however the number two spider on my list
is the only spider that I will trust
with my entire life my entire existence
with my bank account information my
social security everything because
frankly this spider is the bravest and
most skilled of all the spider people in
the spider-verse that's right everybody
I'm talking about that boy that mother
[__] my God just look at him look at
him in the face now look at his little
pawsies very cute stuff a cat in a
jacket look at this boy live his best
life first introduced in the pages of
2019's Peter Porker the spectacular
spider-ham annual meows Morales is the
cat variant of Miles Morales who lives
in spider Ham's world of animal themed
Marvel characters and did you know that
his uncle Heron is secretly The Growler
because I do now and my life is better
for it like including this variant of
Miles Morales in a Miles Morales Trilogy
is an absolute must only listen I did
not want to have to do this but if you
do not all put meows Morales in spite of
verse 3 I'm going to personally come
down to your offices and cry I will cry
so hard that you guys better bring some
aeropods or something because it's going
to be a very awkward day at work I will
cry I love cats okay don't freak out
huh
Miles Morales and I'm Spider-Man but
next up in our number three slot we've
got Donald Glover's Miles Morales from
the Ultimate Spider-Man cartoon the
first appearance of an animated Miles
Morales if you guys didn't already know
the main reason why Miles Morales even
exists in the first place as a character
is because of the actor Donald Glover
specifically the old hashtag Donald for
Spider-Man internet campaign as well as
an old episode of community that had
Donald Glover's character Troy wearing a
Spider-Man shirt in support of the dumb
for Spider-Man movement Marvel creative
God and Legend Brian Michael Bendis saw
Donald Glover in that shirt and was
inspired to create Miles Morales the
character for the comics and this is a
big reason why Donald Glover has been
attached to Spider-Man projects ever
since you know like that time uncle
Aaron was watching him on community in
the first spider-verse movie or that
other time when he was actually uncle
Aaron in Spider-Man homecoming and
across the spiderverse when he's in that
prison so having Donald Glover reprise
the role of that Miles variant is a
no-brainer to me he paved the way for
this new miles in more ways than one but
speaking of no-brainers I am honestly
shocked that we have not seen the lovely
and amazing silk appear in any of these
spider-verse movies like are you kidding
me silk is what we refer to in the
industry as a badass [__] I mean Cindy
moon was bitten by the same spider that
bit Peter Parker right after he was bit
after all and she even hasn't announced
Amazon Prime series called Silk spider
Society so where the hell is she at
because I didn't see her ass at Miguel's
spider cookout I mean is she freaking
locked in a bunker or something oh wait
that's exactly what happened to Silk
when she got her spider powers in the
comics she was literally locked away in
a bunker to keep a group of spider-verse
hunters called inheritors from feasting
on her very flesh but she was eventually
freed by Peter Parker and was inspired
by him to become New York's newest
spider hero on the Block but unlike
Peter Parker Cindy Moon actually has the
ability to shoot organic webbing out of
her fingertips like some type of Toby
Maguire so she is the perfect asset for
miles and Gwen and Beyond the
spider-verse what's that could it be the
ice cream man no it's the pizza man
[Music]
listen I said I wasn't going to include
a live action Tobey Maguire on this list
but I did not say anything about Toby
McGuire for the PlayStation 2 you dummy
you got pranked no but seriously for the
longest time the Spider-Man 2 video game
was considered to be the definitive
Spider-Man experience for anybody who
wanted to feel like Spidey and after
across the spider verse threw in
insomniac's version of PlayStation
Spider-Man as an Easter egg I got so
excited to finally see video game Toby
Maguire make a cameo in the spider-verse
movies but he simply did not show up I
humbly request Sony Pictures correct
this Blast for me post haste because all
of us old Gamers need to hear him say
the line say the line Bart Pizza time if
they made this Spider-Man team up with
the PlayStation 1 and PlayStation 5
Spider-Man in the next film my life
would literally be complete like that
Trio is the video game Trio but those
are my top five spider people that I
would love to be in Spider-Man beyond
the spiderverse but those are just the
top five other spiders that I feel
should definitely be included in the
across the Spider-Man sequel are Emma
Stone and Bryce Dallas Howard spider
Gwen variants Spider-Man UK because
where the hell is Spider-Man UK they
invited the popsicle and Peter parked
car before Spider-Man UK he's a major
spider-verse player in the comments
where is he all four Spider-Man from
these Shattered Dimensions video game
because that game inspired the creation
of the comic spider verse in the first
place Japanese toei Spider-Man with the
freaking
you guys know how much I love Power
Rangers so like where was this man if
miles got crushed by a spider Megazord I
wouldn't have been mad and be like oh
damn there goes the black Spider-Man but
at least I got a Megazord the 80s
cartoon Spider-Man from Spider-Man and
His Amazing Friends Kane Parker the
Scarlet Spider the badass [__]
that he is JK Simmons J Jonah Jameson
Spider-Man from that Spider-Man 2
deleted scene Neil Patrick Harris is
Spider-Man from MTV short-lived
Spider-Man the new animated series
spoderman the internet meme I really
would love to see him in this movie he's
so stupid cosmic Spider-Man the
Spider-Man with the powers of Captain
Universe the electric company's version
of Spider-Man superior Spider-Man
preferably with Catherine Hahn as The
Superior Spider-Man but you know Alfred
Molina is also a legendary and would
also be dope and finally the ruthless
assassin Spider-Man that dude is just a
really badass dude but yes those are all
the spider people that I believe should
be in spider-verse 3. who do you think I
left out do you guys have a personal
favorite that you guys want to see and
be honest fighter verse sound down below
in the comments but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can
on Twitter if you guys want to see me
tweet some weird [__] really fun
theories and please support our growing
Network by buying a spider-verse shirt
or a secret Invasion shirt over at nerd
riot.shop today and if you like live
discussions debates and reactions to the
titles that you love be sure to
subscribe to our live channel the break
room and don't forget to hit the Bell so
that you can be notified when we have
some more analysis to offer because
we've got a lot of cool analysis just
for you anyways thanks again for
watching this video I love you guys so
much and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
thank you